I had to get off my vegan diet a month ago because I was losing too much weight. I got down to
94 pounds. That's not good. I'm five foot one and a half inches. I'm having a problem eating food
as I am scared to eat anything. Don't be scared to eat anything. I was eating peanut butter and banana
sandwiches all day as it called my stomach. How do I change my mindset? It's mostly psychological.
I'm sure. Yes, I would say so. You've got to chill out about your diet.
Remember, we say in your binder, your diet is just your diet. It's a guideline. It's not a
religion. Okay, so it's not going to be a make or break thing. So you got to eat some food. You
got to get your your weight back up. Start enjoying it. God gave you this food to eat. It doesn't mean
you go and eat a McDonald's hamburger, but just eat some food and enjoy food. It's some
read the book on Galatians and don't beat yourself up over your diet. Okay, you're not a Pharisee.
Don't act like one.